was für ein leben seit anderthalb jahren
unterwegs in europa asien australien
pascal lindner 22 jahre jung zimmermann
aus hamburg mitglied der stolzen
handwerks zunft der rechtschaffenen
fremden zimmerer gesellen
der dresscode der gesellenjahre ist klar
die sogenannte kluft und nichts anderes
die schwarze schlag das kommt eigentlich
da ursprünglich daher damit bei der
arbeit keine säge spät in die schule
fällt ja ich meine jackett mit sechs
kräften für sechs tage arbeit acht
knöpfe an der weste für acht stunden am
tag
hier drei jahre lernen und drei reisen
das ist so mein stern die sucht man sich
selber hab ich hier nochmal ganzes
bündel wo das ganze zeug das
arbeitskleidung und wechselwäsche und so
weiter
schlafsack und bei uns steht gut 5
reimann also und wir ziehen den hut
eigentlich vor allem aus seiner kirche
oder zum essen das fünfte element ist
streng möglichst wenig geld ist für die
reise auszugeben
also ist pascal zu fuß oder per anhalter
unterwegs und so verschlug es ihn vor
einigen wochen nach gelterkinden zur
kasseler holzbau wo er nach arbeit
fragte
seit jahrhunderten schon gehen
handwerker auf die walz um ihren blick
zu erweitern
persönlich und beruflich traditionen
werden groß geschrieben
wer wandert sagt lebewohl zu handy zu
facebook im unterschied zu den freunden
zu hause das ist ja ich habe es auch
schon so ich bin frei und kann machen
was ich will sozusagen kann wohin ich
will so das ist halt das schöne das ist
pascal in gnas krauter wie es im
gesellen klein heißt krauter lukas
hassler heuer seit jahren gerne
wandergesellen an
er schätzt ihre währschafte arbeit und
er weiß was mit jungen menschen passiert
die drei jahre in der fremde wein und
das kompliment meistens wenn man ja
sport alleine klarzukommen muss ich halt
alles um alles selber kümmern und man
schläft man arbeitet muss dass ich die
arbeit selber suchen und so weiter
wachsen doch eigentlich sind die lehr
und wanderjahre für pascal ein
bekenntnis zum zimmermanns beruf und
eine fast altmodische liebeserklärung an
sein handwerk
etwas anderes das hat nicht jeder das
ist halt die zeit seinem beruf mehr und
komplett zufrieden damit was mir spaß
ich würde es anders machen aber für den
wanders gesell ist jedes glück eines auf
zeit
bald wird pascal seine kammer neben der
firmen küche wieder räumen er wird sein
bündel schnüren in ein tuch wie dieses
charlottenburger genannten alle seine
habseligkeiten werden darin platz finden
ein aufbruch ganz ohne sentimentalitäten
da fragt man sich was also am meisten
drauf
wir laufen wieder was neues irgendwann
die ganze welt steht pascal offen
nur ein ort ist tabu seine heimatstadt
zu er muss er einen abstand von 50
kilometern einhalten
erst nach drei jahren und einem tag
dafür zurückkehren
eins weiß er schon heute das heimkommen
wird schwieriger sein als das
unterwegssein